attirés amouroux porte-parole du
syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france alors
première question que pensez vous de la
proposition de loi qui est examiné
aujourd'hui par le sénat nous sommes
loin des attentes des professionnels de
terrain c'est à dire que nous avions
trois revendications un rouvrir délit de
créer des postes à vif et troisièmement
revaloriser les salaires
or sur ces trois mesures nous sommes
loin de nos attentes
est ce que le ségur de la santé at il
été utile toutefois alors il ya eu une
légère avance et salariales savoir que
avant le figure les infirmières français
étaient et les -20% sous le salaire
infirmer européen après le cdur nous
sommes à moins 10% le salaire infirmer
européen donc nous sommes toujours
exploité b un peu moi mais il ya quand
même une aberration sur le fait que la
france sur 26 pays de l' ocde était hier
24e et aujourd'hui soutiennent en termes
de salaires affirme européen parce que
du coup bah ya une fuite des jeunes
professionnels qui préfèrent aller
travailler à l'étranger dans des
conditions décentes par concrètement
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour
améliorer justement ce plan qui est
actuellement étudiée alors que l'on
attend avant tout c'est des réouvertures
de lit car faire un gros problème que
nous avons depuis ce jeu des années m a
été augmentée avec le co vide le manque
de lits le manque de lits
d'hospitalisation le manque de lits de
réanimation
or le problème du gouvernement c'est que
nous sommes le seul pays du monde à
continuer de fermer des lits en période
épidémique
c'est à dire que depuis le 1er
déconfinement long
mais ils ont recommencé à fermer d un
peu partout en france y compris ligue
réanimation comme 14 lits et ont été
supprimés au chu de strasbourg
donc on voit bien la différence entre
les besoins du terrain et les décisions
économiques qui l'ont prise c'est à dire
que le projet de loi de financement de
la sécu même s'il ya eu plus d'argent de
pour tenir compte des dépenses
spécifiques aux communes en 2020 eh bien
on se retrouve avec un plan d'économies
d'un recul 4 milliard qui sera imposée
aux hôpitaux cette année ce qui veut
dire encore plus de fermetures de lits
en compte plus de suppressions de postes
alors les personnels de santé du privé
aussi un ne sont pas satisfait par ce
texte
certains avaient même entamé une grève
aujourd'hui vous voyez si vous oubliez
justement de ce plan de santé est ce que
vous comprenez leur colère bien sûr
parce que certains soignants n'ont eu
aucune revalorisation salariale ont eux
ils ont toujours à -20% par rapport aux
salaires affirme européen et puis
surtout il faut rendre les les métiers
attractif c'est à dire que à côté des
suppressions de postes imposées par des
nécessités économiques
à côté de ça il ya des postes qui sont
vacants parce que les conditions
proposées sont incompatibles avec notre
déontologie ou la qualité des freins
lorsque vous avez un ehpad qui recrutent
une infirmière pour 80 à 120 évident
personne n'a envie d'aller travailler
dans ces conditions parce que forcément
derrière il ya de la maltraitance
lorsque vous avez un total qui cherche à
recruter une infirmière pour quinze
passés en médecine ou en chirurgie
forcément vous voyez qu'il ya un
problème de qualité des soins donc voilà
il faut réenchanter l'hôpital vous avez
180 mille professionnels
dernier qui sont en âge d'exercer les
flics faire ce plu parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas travailler sous pays vit en
sous-effectif dans des conditions de
travail qui met en danger la vie des
patients c'est ça la réalité il faut
rendre ces postes attractifs avec des
postes qui soit conforme avec la charge
de travail correctes une qualité du foin
correct pour répondre aux besoins de la
population
merci beaucoup en tout cas thierry
amouroux d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes porte parole
du syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers